[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut à tous aujourd'hui une vidéo un
petit peu spéciale avec un invité par
des démocrates est rien aujourd'hui une
vidéo toute particulière il va y avoir
une vidéo sur cette chaîne avec arnaud
objectivement on va faire un petit jeu
un petit jeu dans le domaine
effectivement de l'high-tech parce que
c'est la thématique de ma chaîne je lui
posais des questions
soit ils y répondent bien et quelqu'un
effectivement et bien j'ai un gaz s'ils
répondent mal ce qui va dès leur arrivée
il aura un diacre admission en suivant
les têtes il est beau et normalement je
suis mon cas et on a fait exactement la
même vidéo avec ces questions dans son
univers directement dans ses locaux à
lui et franchement on l'a tourné juste
avant et ça va l'aider pour sa venue
mais point je vous invite à aller voir
après de bons d'avoir rêvé celle ci
parce que je pensais tu mens alors il
n'a pas stigmates sur la tête
soyez les pattes ils avaient vu juste en
plus on a dix panneaux de 1200 là dedans
il ya tout est légal
les questions sont là dedans et là je
j'ai un petit patch joueurs de bas de ce
qui va se passer
arnaud ne sais pas du tout alors on
avait vu ce qu'il ya dedans j'ai pu
rapidement se sent pas beaucoup mieux
juste avant de parler effectivement pas
de commencer je voudrais avant de vite
faire un os donc à l'angola une chaîne
les mémos d'un terrien c'est une chaîne
de culture culture générale connaissance
connaissance eu pas mal on peut on
découvre des choses
le but c'est curieux c'est pour ça
pourra décrire ça peut compliquer le
mieux si vous êtes curieux c'est de
venir faire un petit tour et regarder un
petit peu ce que je suis exactement il
ya le lien de sa chaîne ici puis on
retrouvera aussi à la fin dans la
description également je vous invite à
aller vous abonner à la chaîne vers
l'autre parce que c'est vraiment cool
voilà allez après avec joue à l'ehpad
gestion là-dessus attention tout suivre
avec le sens d'une faillite est moi je
les souhaite qu'une feuille des efforts
bon alors question numéro 1 est ce que
tu aimerais tu as fait une vidéo il n'y
a pas longtemps sur steve jobs ou tu
t'en rappelles
oui voilà on a parlé de steve jobs tu
veux c'est me piéger sur une des vidéos
je me suis un peu comme but
j'hésite trouver un lien entre ton
univers et venir les lattes 5 armand
steve jobs en janvier
à la question es tu prêt oui quel est le
dernier iphone présenté par steve jobs à
tulle c'est comme ça ou pas comme ça je
crois que cheveux sous la première
proposition iphone 3gs l'iphone 4
l'iphone 4s ou l'iphone 5 alors l'iphone
5 mandats ce qui t'es mort si je me
trompe pas j via call qui attend c'est
vrai c'est ça ma oui mon match important
gage
ça commence à dévoiler la plus grosse
compte quand j'étais tout gamin je
devais être au ce1 la prof nous avait
privés de récré parce qu'on n'avait pas
été gentil je pas quoi il devient très
content également à la récré et abbas et
à l'école % foot
ouais c'est ça recueillant elle nous
prive de récréer j'avais mon stylo à
plume
mais hélas la coloc elle a une robe
blanche du canton rappelle la jupe
blanche wac marqué plus que tu suives
entre il arrivait juste devant moi et l
arrivée à moi est le seul fait de l'eau
aurélien ouais si moi je présente quoi
j'étais tout timide n'allez pas vous
imaginer un gamin un non madame c'est
pas moi et j'ai juré il jurait que c'est
à moi alors qu'ils avaient une flèche
qui arrivait jusque devant la question
numéro deux d'eon avec un canyon oui du
temps avec un cadre a posé une question
sur canal voilà si tu sais le temps
cannon a été créé en 1933 sous le nom
non excusez-moi pour l'action gemalto
japonais saiki cognac ou cake et aux
veaux quelle est la signification est ce
que ça veut dire
kanode version condensée est ce que ça
veut dire laboratoire d'instruments
précision
dick est ce que ça veut dire les mots de
l'optique où est ce que ça veut dire
images photographiques de tokyo j'ai eu
un truc là dessus mais je me souviens
pas du tout généralement ça parce que
j'ai mis un petit clin d'oeil des mémos
mais bon c'est un piège mais les
rhodaniens je dirais dernier tokyo
il m'a storari et tokyo ouais et banon
laboratoire d'instruments de précision
attends je voyais ça trompe pas si tu
vas etre trés trés comme quoi des fois
faut pas chercher à les cacher se
mettent du vernis à ongle subi un
couteau sur twitter
bah non c'est un gage de sérieux
six jeunes hommes et du liant et
justement c'est ça qui est leur ipad
vous secouer les dernières moutures
beauté et de la cemac avec un petit
sourire
troisième question on reste dans
l'univers du smartphone a été de
smartphones c'est très très bien au
quatrième trimestre 2016 quel fabricant
de smartphones arrive leader avec 78 3
millions d'unités vendues apple samsung
huawei ou en pot je suis tiraillé apple
sont plus ce que c'était je dirais ça me
saoule c'est pas mal mais je pense que
you know my way you are what he
prononciation quitté bien du web il a
construit ce match c'était l'espace
chinois ah oui oui ok alors eh ben il va
écoute
non c'est la patte samsung a été leader
sur les trois premiers trimestres de
l'année 2016 et au dernier trimestre
avec la sortie de l'iphone cette île se
repasser leader mais ne peuvent répondre
à la prostitution en juin à nyon quel
est le fabricant du drone spark annoncé
récemment
parrot gopro dj en 3d robotics le tout
la gueule à la bastille arrive vache je
pourrais dire que tu a croqué d'un
bandonéon tout bien tout honneur à la
vague bourget bon beat mon patron c'est
moi que j'ai tout le monde rires comme
tu veux je veux pas rock tu dirais
parrot jeudi à tort chaque dj à elle été
un record sur haïti qu'il colle soyons
bas à [ __ ] c'est mon but ce cinquième
question l'high-tech c'est aussi
automobile qui conerne automobile un
petit peu bon depuis quelle année la
société carglass à équiper son réseau
pour le calibrage de caméras embarquées
ces questions cadeaux ou 2011 2013 2015
2016 c'est sur le réseau france le
réseau français 2016
moi j'ai trouvé 2015 ces réseaux monde
alors parce que non la mesure il a eu
l'agréable et je loge chez carglass je
m'en cache pas besoin bon ben j'ai perdu
mais ouais d'accord peut-être le
raisonnement mais mes réseaux france et
2007 choix il m'avait dit sur un pot
pour moi
soto giflé sais quoi je vais justement
qu'elle tombe là genre [ __ ] j'ai été
mauvais [ __ ] j'suis pas été bon light
accès aussi les consoles et les jeux
vidéo est en hausse et un fan de jeux
vidéo oui ça doit te mets ça oui j'adore
les jeux vidéo mais après je suis pas
toujours soin dernier tout ça donc
parce que tu vois moi l'histoire de
nintendo débute avec excusez moi pour la
prononciation une fois de plus fut sage
bureau iab o'shea dans le domaine des
cartes à jouer
en quelle année est-ce que c'était ça
c'est pas tout j'ai besoin en 1889
en 1936 en 1957 ou en 1974 mais logique
au vernis comme sony et écrire c'est pas
1936 à sa réponse est oui mais c'est
vrai mais avec mr star 1804 9880 je le
sais que j'habite j'ai eu un doute mais
je crois je n'étais pas en plus dévoilé
le prénom de mon plus mauvais coup
j'espère qu'elle regardera pas cette
vidéo
et j'oubliais entraînements mon plus
mauvais coups alors généralement les
oubliettes je crois que son prénom
c'était laetitia désolé laetitia je sais
plus exactement quand ces mêmes
politiciens désolé mais toute façon les
deux amoureux de quelqu'un ou in the
surge de mobiles quelqu'un aussi
enfin j'espère qu'une personne ne leur
dit vous avez le goût de tout le monde
j'ai le goût de quelques questions
numéro 7
oui ça c'est si tu suis l'actualité du
plâtre ou google a été créée en 1998
année où le france était championne du
monde pour ceux qui ne le sauraient pas
pour une seule fois mais pour moi c'est
arrivé et depuis 2015 elle est la
filiale d'une autre société
comment s'appelle cette société à bungie
alphabètes harmonie anderson locaux en 1
semaine quant à vos régions
oui je sais qu'ils ne savent pas c'est
elle fabrique des produits de masse de
chiens alors j'explique un jeu n'est pas
le genre de truc régulièrement
je vais acheter pour une soirée
thématique s'appelait c'est que ces
débauches ne soirée déguisée pas du tout
ce que vous pouvez penser et mon
déguisement préféré mais ça s'achète ans
axiaux et il ya des gens qui prennent
très au sérieux
il s'agit dit elle était prêt tu vas
répondre à la question avec ça va ce qui
est manuel allez vas-y mon petit
laquelle de ces sociétés n'appartient
pas à mark zuckerberg facebook
wayne sapp snap chat ou instagram alors
instagram c'est la même chose c'est
facebook qui compte
whatsapp ou snapshot of us marshall qui
n'appartient pas à un territoire très
bonnes réponses
tu peux enlever sa pomme en verve sur la
garde à deux ils sont vraiment
dégueulasse à café chaud du vol iy le
pire des fossiles copine m'a échappé au
drame
enfin pouvoir au milieu de la nuit donc
oui il faut de macclesfield le pire moi
je dirais que c'est moi c'est qu'on
prend dans sa combine le meur pire
défaut de de ma copine de justin donc
inquiets
la mère de mon fils vit qui moi me
cherche pas d'excusés je vais répondre
là elle va regarder les hanter vite
parce qu'il ya plusieurs tu dois choisir
non non pas du tout si j'ai du mal à en
trouver un il passe la crème les seuls
il s'est sauvé des niches ce soir tu
sais qu'ils les mains pas ce soit comme
ça c'est que des fois même quand elle a
tort elle pense avoir avec ça ça veut ça
ça me saoule mais surtout car j'ai
raison jussie tu regardes ça le soul
vrai nom seul c'est très chiant à temps
a admis qu'il a tort on continue sur
mark zuckerberg facebook un jeu social
network le film sorti en 2010 qui
traitent des députés ebooks a été
réalisée par qui
steven spielberg david fincher martin
scorsese ou quentin tarantino dans une
vie de chat bah c'est vraiment un outil
nous parce que tarantino non mais chine
genre c'est seul que je connais pas
vraiment et les autres jouissant d'une
gomme ça que je suis allé parce que doit
la botte appuyée gérer toutes deux
choses ses causes boire un shooter
maison beaucoup de villers ce qui est
dingue c'est toi qui le menait encore
riche tu dois te sentir ya quoi de la
sauce soja
oui c'est son genre sucré mais non il
est salée cieux aïe ça les démange
j'ai mis la seconde york il s'en dire
que mam qui est une sauce faite à base
de poisson séché qui ne se reconnaissent
japonaise du tabasco
je crois que c'est et d'un coup je suis
pas aulas j'ai dû bosser mes amis nous
avons assez ignoble en même temps de
vous en vouloir qu'à toi même voie
d'accord la deuxième question je les
aime bien parce que c'est vraiment une
question de chance combien de vidéos a
publié jeudi paille au jour
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui hier chance
mais non ça dépend ce qu'on retient
l'idée même de limites
bah tu vas voir 2978 3203 4957 6708 6708
ces mondains d'émouvoir plus tard c'est
4000 et quelque 3200 3g relever les
compteurs hier aujourd'hui c'est ta
journée pour neuf je le mange ne se
faisait vite aller voir sa vidéo tu peux
faire le faux barrage
donc tu peux faire casser le board en
soi le goût non et j'aimerais pas
prouvée mais mange comme ça non ah oui
parce que vous ne trouviez sympa c'est
que l'oeuvre comme ça j'avais pensé à
lui faire quoi au réel mais le bref j'ai
vu c'est que chez moi était périmé c'est
à dire qu'ils ont été malades du cou
avait pas trop mal mais sinon c'est que
j'en ai mangé de plein je suis j'ai fait
de la muscu se voit pas mais j'en ai
mangé plaint déjà comme ça je bouffe et
les hommes cinq mois je voulais faire et
c'est à lui de toi même le manoir bois
je vois pas le matin la science plus
dommage que les protéines je faisais ça
s'est propagé le jeu mais le jeune c'est
trop bon c'est le jeune les protéines
chez grasset leblanc ces deux banques
puissent y ait quelques jeunes ça passe
bien et ça moi j'aime bien c'est tant
mieux tant mieux 5 novembre
bon bah écoute voilà donc on arrive au
bout de cette magnifique vidéo où
j'étais bien pour trait la gueule 1 vous
le dire parce que monsieur monte chez
moi devient dans la rue mais je crois
qu'il est urgent
2 2 non non tu m'avais quoi tu m'as mis
knock down dégueulasse tu m'as mis tout
mon ami 3g mitford égaliser pas prêt
aidé parfaite égalité parfaite
on va prendre match retour dans quelques
one day c'est sympa
en attendant par écouter si cette vidéo
vous a plu je vous invite à mettre des
petits commentaires et à me dire ce que
vous en avez pensé à les voir là la
chaîne dargaud sur tout ce qui est
culture il ya plein de choses c'est
vraiment sympa et je vous invite à aller
vous abonner si la vidéo vous a plu bon
lâche le groupe ou son groupe virtuel où
vivent merci un merci à tous d'avoir
regardé la vidéo est un hors série donc
ça va que c'est un peu particulier mais
avec arnaud en avant très longtemps de
se faire un truc ensemble
c'est vrai qu'à un moment donc il faut
aller voir notre vidéo sur sa chaîne
d'un cc lui qui m'a préparé ces
questions et puis les pièges des opus
charge
ils cherchent pas mal et une belle
gueule j'ai envie d'aller loin merci en
tout cas voir vidéo ci avec plaisir
merci à m
[Musique]
le